[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك ،
أنا فاشل في دوري أبطال أوروبا ، لذا
لا تقلق ، اسمع سأفعل
لأشرح سرًا ، لذا مهما حدث
هنا في الفوز بدوري أبطال أوروبا ،
فزت بدوري أبطال أوروبا ،
فنفوز بدوري الأبطال.  هذا البطل في
دوري أبطال أوروبا ثلاث مرات متتالية ، سأكون
فاشلًا ، سأخبرك بشيء
لديّ ثلاثة آيدولز في حياتي ،
مايكل جوردان تايجر وودز وجوليا
روبرتس ، حسنًا ، هذه هي أيدولز الثلاثة ، لذا
لسبب واضح ، مايكل جوردان و
يمتلكها تايجر وودز وجوليا روبرتس
أيضًا ، لذا جاءت جوليا روبرت منذ سنوات إلى
مانشستر
وليس في عام 1890 قلنا أن أليكس ويلسون فاز
بالألقاب والألقاب وجاءت الألقاب
في الفترة كما لو كنا أفضل من
يونايتد هذه السنوات الأربع أو الخمس هاه
وهو هو  ذهبت لزيارة
مان يونايتد ،
فهي لم تأت لرؤيتنا ،
ولهذا السبب حتى أنني فزت بدوري
أبطال أوروبا لن يتم
مقارنتها بحقيقة
أن الجواهري دائمًا يأتون إلى مانشستر
ولا يأتون لرؤيتنا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية